y That's your Q kid and action
H you did it now
drop I knew it the Marble's at the top
of the tree we'll use this elevator to
get
there this music's pretty catchy
huh
God nuts a plot twist the elevator ain't
going to move until we refill the cup
with
milkshake now had a feeling we were
going he went out and
ined
the they to put him in a
unfor l
man
man with stin and a big
with before the Angels come to carry me
I wanted down how to
me
a polka dot man man give me t with Sho
and a big T
with
Ming
a great work kid one pump running but we
need to get both working before we reach
the
marble
I'm so
alone don't have
no turn on your magic
be Mr s bring me a
dream
bring make her theut
nights are
over I'm
so
don't sand bring me a
dream
please s bless with a
dream make
comps that
in
me I'm so
you did it let's milkshake a Tail
Feather and get that marble you know you
might just be the hero we're looking for
kiddo and cut that's a wrap nice work
kid stick with me and you'll go
far
w